my name is Matthew Buckley my call sign
is whiz and I'm a fighter pilot
I'm going to explain each and every
fighter jet in Top Gun Maverick
so I originally saw the first Top Gun in
1986. it was one of the worst things
that ever happened to me as a result of
that movie everybody wanted to be a Navy
fighter pilot decided to study and try
even harder
[Music]
the first thing I think of when I see
the F-14 Tomcat is a target
big airplane big radar in the front and
massive missiles a Sidewinder which is a
heat-seeking missile the sparrow the
radar missile and the big stick called a
phoenix that could shoot probably 100
plus miles down range
[Music]
in the mid 80s when the original Top Gun
came out the F-14 Tomcat was the
pre-eminent fighters Mission objective
was Fleet air defense responsible for
protecting the entire carrier battle
group from the Soviet horde of bombers
that would attack
at its time the F-14 Tomcat was a pretty
maneuverable aircraft
and at 14 we don't even know if that bag
can fly I think rooster nailed it and I
think he was being nice we also called
it a bullet sponge
so on a good day in the United States
Navy it would be a chore to get an F-14
Tomcat Airborne let alone in a foreign
country that doesn't have the same spare
parts or the maintenance folks there's
only one nation on the face of the
planet that still flies the tomcat and
it's Iran
but to be that tactically proficient
after not flying that jet for a couple
years just a little bit of a stretch in
my opinion
[Music]
pure love
it's the most beautiful airplane on the
face of the planet
The fa-18 Hornet is the first multi-role
fighter attack aircraft a single seat
twin-engine aircraft and it can fly up
to Mach 1.7 Mach 1.8 but the F-18 can
carry all sorts of weapons air-to-air
all the way up to GPS guided weapons and
you can even throw gas tanks on the
airplane and it can also serve as a
tanker aircraft as well
thank you
the filmmakers in Top Gun Maverick just
did an absolutely incredible job the
aviation scenes had me moving in my seat
and and you know squeezing my muscles
together as if I was actually in the
aircraft
when you're flying in an F-18 down at 25
feet going that fast your senses are
absolutely heightened you even sneeze
and it's over with
the aircraft flies that low to the
ground the air can't get out of the way
of the jet fast enough and actually
kicks up all of that dirt the skill
required to do that is pretty incredible
a former Blue Angel actually flew that
maneuver level out coyote
coyote experiences what we call g-lock G
loss of consciousness when you start
pulling multiple G's for example I'm 200
pounds at eight G's it's like a 1600
pound safe is sitting on top of me the
blood's leaving your head so you
actually got to squeeze your legs and
your abs to try and keep you from
passing out if you lose Consciousness at
least back in the day when I started
flying Fighters you die the ground
collision avoidance system is a system
that we have today the jet will give you
a couple opportunities to pull up it'll
start yelling at you and if you don't
respond because you're out the gentle
level the wings automatically and climb
you away from danger
spent nearly almost 3 000 hours in this
airplane one of my first true love Susie
don't kill me and it just uh it's a part
of me it's it's a piece of who I am
I just smile when I see this aircraft
just a beautiful lines of this airplane
the hum of the engine the Rolls-Royce or
the Merlin engine
you can do about 400 to 450 miles an
hour very maneuverable airplane for its
generation the P-51 Mustang is a World
War II fighter aircraft that was used to
escort bombers to strike on Germany but
could also be used in ground attack
missions to strafe enemy tanks
thank you
Tom Cruise actually owns his own you can
buy a P-51 Mustang unfortunately for a
couple million bucks it is not a cheap
aircraft to own or operate
[Music]
so the F-35 interesting looking aircraft
not as sexy looking as the F-18 Hornet
the F-35 lightning can go about Mach 1.6
about 1200 miles per hour if you
actually look at the aircraft it's a
lifting body aerodynamic so it can glide
the single engine also rotates so the
nozzle actually moves to make the
aircraft turn tighter in a turn Circle
and also to fire off weapons
[Music]
so the first time we see the F-35
lightning II we see it on the flight
deck of the USS Abraham Lincoln CVN 72
which was the ship I did my first
deployment on in 1995. the F-35 is
definitely a fifth generation aircraft
many fifth generation aircraft are their
own self-contained strike package so to
speak back in the day when I flew we'd
have F-14 Tomcats to an air superiority
A6 is doing bombing and we'd also have
jamming aircraft many fifth generation
aircraft are all three of those in one
they have electronic warfare capability
that can jam the enemy's radar and
Communications they have air-to-air and
air-to-ground capability as well plus
the stealth features are just off the
charts so fifth generation aircraft if
you go up and touch them it'll actually
feel a little spongy because they have
radar absorbent material aside from the
exterior radar absorbent coating of the
aircraft they internalize the weapons if
there's anything hanging off of a
fighter jet that reflects radar energy
so all the weapons are internalized in a
fifth generation aircraft
so the su-57 Felon very appropriately
named because they stole this this is
essentially the F-35 ski so to speak
so the su-57 fell and is essentially the
F-35 copy paste similar weapon systems
similar electronic warfare capabilities
[Music]
foreign
on the face of the planet outside of
helicopters that can actually tell if
it's being locked up by an infrared
missile and it can actually shoot at
that Warhead and disintegrate it or
disable it it's called durkum direct
infrared countermeasures
today dog fighting is extremely rare
when our enemy pilot leaves his house
and gets to the air station we know that
that's already happened if you're in a
dog fight in today's day and age a lot
of things have broken down
whenever you're doing a dog fight is who
can turn tighter
because the su-57 can carry some pretty
serious air-to-air missiles so if I were
the su-57 Felon driver I would have
pitched out of the visual range of the
dogfight went out a couple miles and
turned around and shot Maverick in the
face with a radar missile but I wasn't
the director
[Music]
the Dark Star as depicted in Top Gun
Maverick although a fictional aircraft
or maybe not
foreign
so the Dark Star Jed might actually be
real developed in what we call the Skunk
Works the Skunk Works is out in the
middle of the Mojave Desert where they
develop all of our black box type of
aircraft if you can think about it it
probably exists there's probably guys
and gals in a windowless room over air
conditioned with Mountain Dew and pizzas
designing it and building it
the Dark Star aircraft is kind of based
on the SR-71 Blackbird it was a very
high altitude aircraft on the edge of
space that could do reconnaissance on
demand Recon as we call it kind of looks
stealthy very Sleek very fast and it
also has hyper Cruise engines so for
example an F-18 Hornet that I flew to
get supersonic full left hand forward
full Max afterburner a lot of dinosaurs
being burned a lot of fire out of the
back as technology and engines improve a
lot less fire required a lot less energy
required to get to a certain point and
based on how the airframe is designed it
can actually super Cruise so it can fly
faster longer and on less fuel required
and less fire
so Maverick more or less destroys the
Dark Star aircraft
not a career enhancing move I just
happen to break a 65 million dollar F-18
Hornet I went from the edge of space to
straight down at the Pacific doing about
Mach 1.7 and I over stress the aircraft
that was not career enhancing either but
I saved the aircraft I did eject like
Maverick did so let's just say I got out
as a lieutenant I don't know how he made
it to Captain busting up airplanes like
that but after destroying the Dark Star
he certainly isn't going to get selected
for admiral
[Music]
it's not incredibly difficult to fly a
fighter jet and I know that might sound
a little crazy based on how it looks but
the training is so good I'm a poor kid
from South Jersey South Philadelphia and
I'm not the sharpest tool in the shed
and if I can do it just about everybody
can do it as well
[Music]